what's the deal with airplane
peanuts the year of 2023 was packed with
wild comedy moments and after watching
this video you'll be caught up with
every detail this is the joke World
comedy news year in review every single
week on this channel we cover the most
interesting and impactful stories
related to The Comedy Universe 2023
started off hot with an ongoing feud
between Tom sagora and Eerie
Pennsylvania that resulted in beef
between Tom and the local Eerie
weatherman at the time David Walters
beef that started after Walters
responded to Tom's Eerie rant by calling
him out on their local news I heard for
Tom the reason he's so mad is because he
wasn't voted in the top 10 of the
sexiest bald men alive that's what I'm
hearing okay Tom responded to this call
out by challenging David Walters to a
one-on-one basketball game in Austin
Texas the stakes were if Tom lost he
agreed to donate $5,000 to a charity of
Walters choice and if he won David
Walters had to make his Instagram public
for a a year to let ymh fans go to town
and post a public apology and at this
time it was still unclear if David would
accept Tom's basketball challenge I
think you're too much of a [__] and you
won't do it
but choice is yours the next comedy news
update was January 9th titled comedians
react to the christalia problem which
was a video that highlighted the
reactions of various comedians such as
Nikki Glazer Tim Dylan and Annie
Letterman to a popular YouTube
documentary that detailed the sexual
assault out allegations made against
Ayah back in 2020 New Year's resolution
for Chris Ayah what do we
think throw your phone in the
ocean no don't let them break you Chris
don't let them break you in uh change
your facial hair and throw your phone in
the
ocean in 2023 crystalia needs to stop
worrying about what everyone thinks and
just go for
it on January 17th we covered Louis K's
big announcement that he would be
returning to Madison Square Garden for
the first time in over a decade you
doing the garden yes are going back to
the Garden that's huge yes I'm really
excited I like that room it's you know
in terms of doing standup comedy is that
a room where you go this is the
Pinnacle uh no I mean to me honestly any
great show is the Pinnacle so like I
I've done the garden eight times in my
life and uh it was important enough to
remember it was 8 I don't know how many
times I've been to the club Funny Bone I
don't know how many times beside being a
Monumental return for Lou this event was
extra newsworthy because there were
tickets available for purchase to a live
stream of the show on Lou ck.com which
gave you access to the performance for
10 days before it was removed forever
this also took place around the time of
Chris Rock elective outrage which was
the first Netflix live streaming comedy
event after starting off with Stories
full of either beef drama or returns to
Glory we had our first sad report of the
the year on January 23rd with the
passing of kill Tony Hall of Famer
Michael Lair the first ever inducted to
the brand new kill Tony Hall of Fame
ladies and gentlemen this is Michael
[Applause]
Lair
stand shut the [__] up January ended
with a unique episode of The Comedy news
that covered a handful of smaller topics
including the Netflix movie you people
featuring Andrew Schultz and Eddie
Murphy and a full review and Analysis of
the Louis CK back to the Garden live
stream thank you for coming for
tonight's performance Louis
CK we have a few rules and regulations
before we start due to covid-19 please
don't do anything during the show also
anal sex is not allowed in the arena
please go to the lobby for the anal sex
notable January standup specials include
Andrew Santino cheeseburger Louis CK
back to the garden and Nate baratti
hellow world the month of February
started off with Dave Chappelle winning
the Grammy award for best comedy album
marking his fourth consecutive win in
this category despite being named the
winner Dave Chappelle was not present at
the Grammys to accept his award which
confirmed many people's beliefs of the
declining interest and significance in
award shows in general uh so the winner
is not here so the acate Academy accepts
this on their behalf all right
congratulations next up was comedians
appearing in various Super Bowl
commercials on February 13th including
David Lucas Jeff Ross Neil Brennan Tommy
Pope and H Foley Sarah Tiana made it
everyone congratulations to
her Sarah is a Georgia Peach and just
like a Georgia Peach she gets ignored at
the grocery
stores following the Super Bowl Bert
crer and Tom sagora took a trip down to
the Daytona 500 for live episode of two
bears W cave that was unlike anything
we've seen before I feel like I'm not
even joking in 5 years I think two bears
racing can be contenders in the Daytona
[Applause]
I I think we're going to need you to
take a pivot from this comedy career and
focus on your racing besides being the
week that Robert Kelly replaced Dan
Soder on the bonfire we uploaded our
first interview of the year on February
27th with Christa Stefano where he red
Reve his new gig hosting a show on Vice
TV called super maximum retro show as
well as plans for what was his biggest
show to date at the time at Radio City
Music Hall thank you so much uh I I'm in
Vancouver right now so uh it's it's nice
it's really nice if you like fish if you
like the mountains and if you like Asian
women then I would come to Vancouver
notable February standup specials
include Mark Marin from Bleak to dark
and Roseanne Bar cancel this March 2023
was a historic month in standup history
because this is the month that Joe Rogan
finally opened the comedy Mothership in
Austin Texas it's honestly hard to
believe it hasn't even been a full year
since this club officially opened with
all the exposure the mothership has
already brought to the comedy World it
feels like it's been around for years
now comedy Mothership in Austin Texas
this club is too hard to resist shout
out to Joseph Rogan everything is utter
Perfection it's perfect
it's a perfect Club perfect Vibe it's
The Comedy Store of
steroids that's all I can say Aros Smith
is AOS Smith Guns and Roses is AOS Smith
on steroids if you really think about it
just one level of more explosiveness
this is what this comedy mothership is
one week after the grand opening was
kill Tony's Mothership debut the number
one live podcast in the world had been
seeking temporary shelter in various
comedy clubs around Austin while waiting
for their new home to be built and with
the overwhelming significance of this
event to the comedy world we hired local
Austin Comic Chandler ran to gather some
boots on the ground interviews Chandler
welcome to the show thank you for being
with us here today please tell us what's
it look like out there the scene leading
up to the first ever kill Tony at Joe
Rogan's club uh everyone seems really
excited Jake uh everyone seems to be
lining up there's a huge line out here
outside lots of comics from all over the
place from Canada and New York just from
all over just trying to sign up for this
show uh the energy seems very great uh
people are seem very excited and I think
people really want to see what it's like
to be on the main stage of this new
great uh comedy venue would you stab
somebody for a spot tonight I would stab
everyone in this line for for 2 minutes
wow wow you heard it here first dude
Jake people are out here willing to kill
to get into this Comedy Club hi Jake I'm
here on the scene with mass Wayne Mass
what do you how do you feel about kill
Tony and uh it being at the mothership
for the first time in it opening
uh I feel the same I guess Charles Adams
Jr uh Charles how do you feel about this
uh you know this first kill Tony on a
Monday at the comedy Mothership uh man
it's all good my feet hurt I wish they
give us some chairs or something would
you stab a guy for a chair I will [__] a
dude up right here on Sixth Street right
here for a [__] chair I would
hard too on March 21st 2023 Tom sagora
and David Walters squashed their beef by
playing a one-on-one basketball game to
21 the first comedy news story of the
year coming Full Circle 3 months later
was definitely fun to watch especially
because with the amount of challenges
getting thrown around at ymh that don't
ever come to fruition it was almost
assumed that this would never happen in
real life that's ball game
folks look I don't think suicide is
something to joke about but if I had
lost him I would have killed myself
overall it was pretty cool to watch
David Walter finally Embrace Tom and the
ymh fans lean into some of these jokes
playing this game and accept these
challenges he posted the agreed upon
apology video that was full of all the
ymh lingo he's picked up from his
comment section the past few months I'd
love to talk about Hawaii but I have
some important things to say I'd like to
take this opportunity to apologize to
Tom saguro he's a very smart and sexy
bald man and personally I think he
should be at the top of the sexiest bald
man alive list he's got that beautiful
mouth and he's built in such a way my
brother didn't believe me at first but
he believes me now I said i' destroy Tom
on the basketball court and I didn't he
proved himself to be a worthy opponent
I'd like to think we've gained respect
for each other both personally and on
the court congrats Tom you beat me as
far as the rematch goes if you want to
do it again you better believe me I'm
coming up in May one week after that
Brian Redban announced he would be
opening a comedy club called the Sunset
Strip right down the street from the
comedy Mothership adding even more fuel
to the flourishing comedy fire in Austin
Texas notable standup specials in March
included Chris Rock selective outrage
Kelsey cook the Hustler Bert Cher
razzled Dazzle and Jeremiah Watkins
daddy the drama started early in April
with the censorship of Matt R we got hit
with a bunch of restrictions one of
which being an age restriction that
would require all viewers to be not only
proven that they're over 18 but they'd
have to have a registered official
YouTube account to be able to access it
which is insane considering most people
do not have a YouTube account that
defeats the entire purpose of YouTube
being such a sharable website and we
also got hit with a music a music
restriction for the song I paid
thousands of dollars for the rights for
um but they did not accept the um
confirmation I guess if you want to call
it so it's completely dead in the
YouTube algorithm which means strangers
will never find it uh you guys can't
watch it unless you have an account so I
have to delete it incredibly frustrated
and I'm very very sorry so for the few
of you who got to watch it I hope you
liked it I'll figure it out as well as
the roast of Burke crer on only fans TV
B you also have one of my favorite jokes
and you guys have probably heard it in
every one of his
specials it starts with take off his
shirt blah blah blah some situation
comes up that isa's in and then Isa says
and I
quote
[Applause]
Jus
say she
go dot dot dot something you made up
that Isa
[Laughter]
said up next was the official skang Fest
lineup announcement making big news
specifically because it featured Brendan
sha and Brian Callen performing a live
taping of the fighter and the kid this
was especially interesting because of
the many jokes made at Brendan shab's
expense from the Legion of skanks
members and fans so fans were extra
curious to see how this was going to
play out and if you stick around till
the end of this video you'll find out
because we went to skang Fest Vegas this
year to report it all live us can I tell
you why I've taken shots and I have made
jokes is because it's like it's like the
button you're not supposed to push for
some reason I don't know why it for some
reason it's like a thing you're not
supposed to say so it makes me want to
say it more as a comic I don't know
that's always been where is on April
18th Joey Diaz announced plans to
release a personal Memoir titled
tremendous the life of comedy Savage
which details his journey from a
troubled youth to discovering his
passion for comedy overcoming addiction
and depression and his rise to fame as a
comedian and actor the next comedy news
update was an extra special episode
because we traveled all the way to
Austin Texas to see the comedy
Mothership up close and Report firsthand
on what the new club is actually like as
well as giving an in-depth review of The
Joe Rogan and friend show that featured
Brian Simpson Tony henchcliffe Jim
Brewer and more notable April standup
specials include Matthew Steven R Ryan
sickler Lefty son big J ogron dog belly
and John meany Baby J Andrew Santino
Bobby Lee and bad friends started off
the month of May on the road during
their first ever theater tour which
included 25 minutes of stand up from
each member followed by an hour of live
podcasting this tour came at the perfect
time for Bobby as he was in the midst of
dealing with a small group of
ticktockers trying to lightly cancel him
I knew I said it I said this is exactly
what we need to start the tour in
Vancouver with a big huge audience of
people in Canada that were like so exed
and we were leaving I go let's go we got
to get a car what and she goes um no I
want to go back on the stage again so I
went with her I made him come with me
and she goes look and you know this
beautiful theater such a pretty theater
beautiful oh my God I could see her tear
up right and I went you know what you
just taught me a lesson this is it this
is it this is it there's nothing else
live in it right now right now you
really taught me a lesson I was so glad
because I didn't tell you at the time
but I think it was cuz I was pretty
drunk
so wasn't a real emotion no it's real
but it was fueled but but you were like
are you getting emotional and then I was
like yeah and then you started wa wait
wait wait stop you weren't emotional
then you were Faking It Well I didn't
want to tell you I think a lot of it was
because of the alcohol yeah but it was
still real spiritual I had a spiritual
profound moment you were [__] drunk
up next is the highest viewed comedy
news update from 2023 the entire theovon
vers barol Sports beef this man's coming
at us this man for whatever reason why
especially if you're just going to get
hurt every year not even play say this
past weekend a phenomenal podcast
actually I was a massive fan was I am
yeah I guess was we was Compton I think
his eyesight's real bad he has CT he has
CT EFG dude I saw this drama between
Will Compton from busing with the boys
and theovon from Covington Louisiana all
start started as a practical joke when
will decided to text Theo the fake news
that Theo's good friend Caleb Presley
had passed away while at the hospital
unfortunately Theo's plane took off
before the clarifying messages could
ever be delivered let's tell Theo you
died tell Theo you did it and you die so
he text you and he was like dude did you
hear what happened to Caleb and you hit
him back right away you're like what
happened and he was like he passed away
and then he immediately took a photo of
me doing like this in my little gown but
then you were on a plane so the photo
didn't come in photo didn't come yeah
and he's like I'm absolutely gutted
that's what he said with the photo I
guess and so that's all I got and then
that Wi-Fi kept cutting in and out like
yeah was I was that a little much and
far absolutely but anything for a nice
little laugh yeah you know what I'm
saying and I knew Theo like Theo and I
don't know each other that well and if
you're live in the world of Giggles yeah
yeah yeah All is fair yeah yeah yeah it
was a huge year for comedy going
independent as on May 16th 20123 Dave
Chappelle announced official plans to
open his own comedy club in Yellow
Springs Ohio the club club which is
named live from Yellow Springs sits
inside an Old Firehouse and has a
restaurant attached dude now I'm
inspired so whatever he's going to do in
Yellow Springs is going to be very
interesting cuz it's I think he's doing
120 seats holy [__] I think he's doing a
size the size of little boy damn dude
yeah imagine that like you can go to see
Dave Chappelle at any given night in his
backyard what a great idea though like
he's Dave Chappelle he could do that
anywhere like why not why not like build
your own club and have the people come
to you because of course they're going
to come to da Bert Cher's Blockbuster
movie the machine was hot in the streets
to close out the month of May with
backtack comedy news updates first
discussing the potential impact of this
movie leading up to the release date and
The Following episode post Premiere
weekend discussing the box office
results and Tom sora's Premiere party
surprise doesn't reply hey man are you
going to make it to the premiere please
tell me to make it to the premiere no
reply and then call him and he's like
hey man I can't [__] make it and I go
actually I'm actually bothered by it
like I'm bother I you're my best friend
we have a podcast together and we have a
movie set up over at legendary fat
astronauts you guys need to make it no
one no one replies no one replies Tom
hits me up I have a publicist texting me
this morning I have a signing for my
book which is going into
paperback oh yeah when it does make the
move from hard to paper it is a deal big
deal a very big deal big [__] deal
and he goes I can't get out of it I'm
coordinating with my publisher and it's
Barnes & Noble it's kind of a big deal
it's coming out in paper deck and I
aren't they closing down yeah yeah
Didn't They I'm the fool in this story
cuz I'm listening to Barnes & Noble he's
like plus I have a VHS signing at
Blockbuster and fries and I think I got
to go Fries electronics and I think uh
straight guys can get AIDS and he's like
all the things that we thought back then
and I said I got you no worries and he
goes hey man congrats on your big day
I'm so sorry I couldn't make it very
excited to see you in this movie and in
movie theaters have a great weekend I
love you have fun and I just wrote
thanks Tommy I wish you could be here I
understand I love you and then
this shows up he showed up I know that
cuz you told me that he showed up I did
beautiful and I cried he cried notable
May standup specials include Jimmy o
yangang guess how much this Summer
started off with the biggest kill Tony
episode ever celebrating the 10year
anniversary of the show The 10-year show
took place in Austin Texas in front of
3,000 people and featured special guests
Joe Rogan and Tom sagora popins from
theovon and Ron White as well as the
retired of David Lucas the addition of
Cam Patterson and the Hall of Fame
induction of William mountgomery you are
a star we saw Hans uh is dealing with
being challenged regularly for his
regular ship we saw David Lucas retire
with dignity able to do spots anytime he
wants you're the second ever inducted
hall of fame member of the kill Tony
Universe thank you so much are
you are you also planning on retiring or
are you going to keep uh performing
every week Tony I never go
stop you know I never go stop on June
13th Matt re broke the Internet by
putting tickets on sale to his first
ever 140 City World Tour and while the
story did go viral online for a few days
I mean he literally broke the internet
or at least ticket Master's website we
discussed the truth about his rise to
Fame in this episode as well as the
dangers of cultivating an audience full
of Comedy rookies in life did he not
have a job the entire time you guys
together he did he did work in the ER he
worked in the ER oh I'm sorry you broke
up with a hero in mid June we got big
news from your mom's house that they
would be adding more shows under their
umbrella although it obviously shares a
name with their longest running podcast
ymh has always been a podcast Network
eager to expand hosting past shows with
comedians like Josh Potter and Ryan
sickler and this year adding new shows
like the Danny Brown Show not today pal
and first date with Lauren Compton so
you're joining a studio uh that has one
of the most rabid and DieHard fan bases
anywhere on the internet has there been
pressure felt like joining that family
have you gotten any early feedback from
the ymh community they announced it on
social media and I shouldn't read the
comments I know better than that you
know I'm like I should know better but
for some reason a part of me was like
I'm going to go read the comments today
and you know they're like oh she goes on
Dr Drew and she has big tits this is Tom
doing you know and I'm like God damn it
like I work really hard to have like
good personality for you people and all
you can see is my
boobs but I feel like the the show
itself is so entertaining so I'm just
hoping that maybe they stir up so much
around the show where they're like this
show is going to be [__] and hopefully
that makes people want to actually tune
in to find some validation in the
[__] that they're saying and see
that there's actually more to the show
than they thought up next is possibly
the most bizarre situation to ever carry
real life repercussions I am of course
talking about the thermostat beef a
long-standing feud between Berke Cher
and Bobby Lee's agents Matt Blake and
Nick Nero which had been hindering
Bert's ability to work with comedians
represented by Matt Blake such as Bobby
Lee Andrew Schultz and Tim Dylan who
were all blocked from joining this
year's fully loaded Festival right so
they used to work together at a agency
and they hated each other because of the
temperature of the room they fought over
the temperature right so would like it
hot how am I how am I just hearing about
this An Origin story man yeah this is
like this is real thermostat beef
because I will tell you ther brief
thermost it's about the temperature of
the office notable standup specials from
June include Ali sadik the domino effect
part two and Matteo Lane hair plugs and
heartache during the beginning of July
we saw YouTube sensor ship really start
to affect comedians more often the most
famous example of this being Theo V's
episode with Roseanne Bar being removed
from YouTube and consequently becoming
the most viewed podcast episode ever
after being uploaded to Twitter and
shared by Elon Musk Tim Dylan was also
fighting a censorship war of his own
with YouTube around this time a battle
that made him question his Show's entire
future on this platform there there are
other places you know we might start
uploading the show to Twitter we're
thinking about it in addition to YouTube
we don't know we might start uploading
the show to rumble we don't know right
now but we are experimenting with all
kinds of things but we don't know the
direction that things are going to go in
the media space but things do seem to be
heading to an interesting place where
there are more eyeballs now across many
different platforms and that might be
the best way to do it the next big
comedy story of 2023 was the viral beef
between Andrew Schultz and steiny from
nek after it was revealed by happy Dad
President John sahiti that the full sun
podcast only had one episode they
couldn't release a recording from over a
year ago that captured all the awkward
moments of Andrew Schultz roasting
steiny to the point that he asked for
the episode to never even be aired
schles thought that you were like
digging at him for for certain [__] so
then he was chirping you back and then
you guys just kind of went at it for
like 5 minutes and then schs was going
in on steiny and stuff like that and
then after the podcast schles just kind
of approached me and John and said yo
like I don't know if that was really it
like I feel like if I want to be on the
Pod like we could do something way
bigger and some [__] that's like really
going to break the internet you didn't
wanted out either at all okay well let's
that that's that's for sure the the
reason I okay that's but that's also not
exactly true because I remember saying
like yo bro no you didn't bro no no this
you're way more wa no no you're way more
accepting now yeah for sure but back
then you were like bro no I'm that's
going to cause like you can you allow me
real quick but what I did say was can we
maybe take certain things out and we
could put it out and you said yeah sure
I pretty early on realized that like
Kyle and Stein don't really know me that
well cuz the questions they're asking
are like really basic questions what an
example has anybody ever like heckled
you and I there's a moment in the pot I
don't know if they edited but where I'm
like what and they're like like have you
ever like talked to someone in the
crowd and like
so I'm thinking so I'm thinking two
different things in this moment I'm
going either they have no clue who I am
and that's weird that I would even be
here annoying yeah
or they know and it's a
troll so I'm I'm like
H do you know what I mean like and in
though you know in that
moment steiny got uh he got CLI now he
knows what you do yeah the summer kept
rolling along with Tom sora's latest
standup special Sledgehammer hitting
Netflix on July 4th watched uh I watched
Sledgehammer last night oh thanks and it
was I don't watch specials or I do but I
turn you know you turn them off you turn
them off I was laying right there I
haven't laughed out loud at a special in
a very I was by myself at like midnight
laying right here
[Laughter]
like the the closer made me oh thanks
was dying dude my personal favorite
episode this year was on July 25th when
we interviewed Mark Norman while he was
on the toilet just hours before the
release of his first fulllength special
on Netflix Soup To Nuts your last
special on YouTube is currently at
around 12 million views you were verily
early on the YouTube wave for comedians
putting on full specials to their own
channels was there any hesitancy to go
with Netflix this time after seeing just
how perfectly it worked on YouTube last
time or was it always a goal to have a
ful length 50-minute special our special
on Netflix regardless another great
question boy you know your you know your
comedy Biz that's righty um yeah it's
great it's great having a guy on the
other side because all the comedians
know all this [__] and you can't talk to
anybody about it who's not a comedian
but you're you're a nerd like us
basically I love YouTube YouTube is
great it's great for comedy these
Gatekeepers suck you know they're it's a
business at the end of the day so they
they got no balls they don't want to
take a risk on a guy or a gal or a
non-binary but I think I got the YouTube
crowd I feel like I won that fight and
then I'm like let me see if I can win
the Netflix crowd and I'll own it in two
years anyway so I can just put it on
YouTube so it's a win-win and you get a
couple bucks so I figure hey let's mix
it up and I get it back anyway that
makes a lot of sense that seems awesome
notable July standup specials include
Tom sagora Sledgehammer Kevin Hart
reality check Jeffrey asmus the only
funny white man Mark Norman Soup To Nuts
and Jim Gaffigan dark pale the Just for
Laughs comedian of the Year award was
given to Bert prer on August 1st 2023 an
award that was well earned after the
machine sold over 450,000 tickets last
year Rolling to an incredible $32.9
million in 2023 somehow well up from $23
million in 2022 meaning that Bert now
has a bigger yearly salary than Tyreek
Hill it was also during this episode we
announced there would be a vote at the
end of the year for joke World comedian
of the year which we'll have more
information about at the end of this
video I one comedian of the year I'm
just accepting an award
the next week we saw the release of
artificial birth a musical album by Joe
D Ro's band salsa winfall I don't know
if you saw the clip of this last hey bab
episode with Chris and sa where they're
listening to the song you put out and
they're trying to figure out what the
name salsa windfall even means I think
someone said it sounds like a burrito
buffet in Orlando the name of his band
is salsa windfall I did he ever explain
that wait wait hold on a second stop
this that literally sounds like a that
sounds like a burrito place in Orlando
yeah does the name actually mean
anything or how did you and Paul come up
with that Paul came up with it we were
in the apartment I remember we were just
we were young man and we we got a bunch
of weed weed was a really special thing
back then you know it's not like now
where it just falls out of every tree
you walk by getting your hands on weed
and getting to use it and smoke it was
was awesome and special and we we had a
bunch of weed and we had a bunch of I
don't know beer or some kind of liquor
and he said we should record while we're
there and he was starting to get into
cook and he was like I'll cook he made
this big uh Mexican spread one night was
like tacos and all kinds of stuff we
were a few songs in and I was like what
do you think we should call this and
he's like we should call it salsa
windfall he was holding a jar of salsa
and I was like okay my vocabulary was so
poor I didn't even know what the word
windfall meant yeah I was about ask yeah
I thought it was a fart joke and then
like like months later he's like no
windfall means like a lot I was like oh
yeah I was Imaging like a waterfall of
salsa it means like you know like we
have a windfall of you know uh
hamburgers or whatever it's a ton of
hamburgers the next video was a detailed
comparison of The Comedy Store in Los
Angeles and the comedy seller in New
York specifically how comedians from
each City are treated when they perform
in the other City's comedy clubs the
seller gives us everything we want the
seller treats us like kings they should
everything we want they give us they
make us feel like at home we love it
there and I'm mad that our club M
doesn't have the same it should be
reciprocation should be reciprocation
right it should feel like you know East
Coast and West coast rappers no more war
yeah peace yeah yeah reciprocate yeah
reciprocate y'all not give a about death
row yeah yeah you know what's so funny
yeah it is they do treat I mean the
people over there at Celler I I've
talked about on the show they treat it's
so nice it's not just nice and it should
feel that way when guys come here I
prefer it in a weird way in late August
it was officially announced that Bill
Burr's movie Old dads was set to debut
later this year on Netflix for a while
it was up in the air if this project
would ever get done due to the unlikely
circumstances that forc Burr into making
his directorial debut cuz I I wrote
something and I shot it but I I wasn't
in it I was in it for like two seconds
but to be like the amount of lines that
I had and to be directing and the only
reason why I did it was be I because I
had to because no one was available
because it was it was the uh out of the
pandemic all the directors had what they
were going to shoot and then their next
thing so usually if they just have one
thing you can try to squeeze something
in it's only 24 days that's all it was
um but people are had you know this
thing and the last thing so they already
had so everybody was booked so then they
they started coming hey man you should
direct it and I was like no no no no I
don't want to act I don't want to be
acting and direct that's too much and
then they were like it's just well it's
going to go away I mean it's going to go
I was like and the second I said okay oh
like the the um the the level of work
that directing is I had no I had no idea
like you have to answer every single
[__] question like this is when I
knew I was in
trouble um uh we there was one scene
like uh our set director right lovely
person she comes up to me she goes okay
in this scene there's going to be a
barbecue I'm like yeah all right cool
and she goes were we thinking paper
plates I'm like yeah yeah paper plates
and she goes what kind of paper plates
and I
just [__] PE go to
Ralph's whatever you find like and then
then I got in my head going like oh my
God like some directors give a [__]
about this Dave Chappelle turned 50
years old to end this month and
celebrated his birthday in style with a
star studded show at Madison Square
Garden that featured Shane Gillis Mike
Tyson Chris Rock and Travis Scott Happy
Birthday
[Applause]
to happy
bir
notable August standup specials include
Matt mccusker the speed of light Jared
freed 37 and single Adam Ray live from
Portland and Joe list special enough for
everybody September started off with
breaking Shane Gillis news as it was
announced on the real ass podcast that
Not only was Shane the next comedian
moving to Austin Texas but that he was
also bringing his podcast partner Matt
mccusker and the other members of their
Philadelphia New York crew I want to
make a special announcement right now
okay ladies and gentlemen Shane Gillis
is moving to Austin Texas oh boy
that is not that is not public
knowledge yeah
whatever dude that's awesome of you it
is that's so cool dude yeah I hate this
[__]
town but I guess I'll live here it seems
like it seems like you hate it I
actually yeah I don't it's
fine what's making you move here uh
what's for you to move here I don't know
if I'm legally allowed to say it but you
can legally say Joe Rogan taxes
yeah no state taxes
yeah huge property taxes it's going to
be very funny yeah I'm not going to I'm
going to
rent that' be funny when the IRS is like
here this clip from the real ass podcast
I'm moving here for tax purposes is that
illegal though can you can't say that I
don't think yeah can say Shut why not
upon that don't they you say yeah I
guess I'm not that worried about it I
just said it into a microphone never
forget the September tragedy that was
Joe Liss getting his latest special hit
with multiple YouTube restrictions a few
days after uploading stopping all the
momentum of enough for everybody right
in its tracks maybe I'll be one of these
guys you know like these uh these
grifters wow the people that are like I
they they got me right you know help me
out or whatever yeah he'll be at the
capital in the year cuz Schultz he I
mean he blew up cuz he he was on Barry
Weiss because he had to change something
or something yeah yeah too offensive
some streamer wouldn't have him whatever
the story is but he made a cool 5 mil I
do think you should throw it up on
Twitter as well f it the whole special
yeah nothing but the special
God I do but uh I think you know you you
throw it up on Twitter cuz the theop
pod's an hour and 40 this is an hour
right interesting okay maybe I'll do it
with just a few weeks left in September
our next episode focused on the history
of sober October a JRE tradition between
Joe Rogan Tom sagora Bert ker and arish
shafir after adjusting the rules last
year to make things less competitive but
still plenty challenging it was unclear
whether or not sober October was even
happening this year I'm not going into
sober October half ass I'm definitely
charging every one of you mother just
like I did last year when you're doing
80% of your max heart rate for a minute
you get one point I had 1,00 points and
I read the comments and they weren't
hurtful they were like people concerned
and I was like if that's how people are
seeing me that's not how I want to be
seen I want to be seen like Nas on
September 27th 2023 a story published in
the New Yorker about Hassan Minaj made
major headlines for claiming that many
of the stories told in his Netflix
special King's gesture including a story
about his daughter being exposed to
Anthrax and another about being harassed
by an FBI agent were completely made up
wait but Andrew yes comedians makeup
stories all the time that's true now
usually we do it to make things funnier
not make things more racist or sad or
emotional yeah and I think that's the
tricky thing here in his stories it's
not like he was using these
exaggerations or hyperbole as punchlines
he was using them to kind of make the
audience feel worse about him and then
it turns out these things didn't
actually happen notable September
standup specials include Shen Gillis
beautiful dogs L J Gomez and colum
Terrell 30 minutes and Michelle wolf
it's great to be here October started
off with a video breaking down some of
the massive upcoming Arena shows for
Andrew Schultz and Tony Hinchcliffe as
well as covering the insane demand for
comedy right now in general he I'm so
sorry to say this but we can't you kill
Tony on that Sunday because we're only
doing it in Austin now and uh blah blah
blah blah blah and a bunch of other
stuff blah blah blah we're in Arena act
uh blah blah blah sold out Arenas in our
hometown I know I was trying to save you
from looking like a douchebag um it was
also during the month of October that
bad friends hit 1 million Subs on
YouTube way in the meantime we're
celebrating our 1 million
subscriber can I just say though those
that's for my Golden Chicken our next
video covered some current comedy
history when we were joined by Brian
Simpson to talk about being the first
comedian to record a special at the
comedy Mothership filming your special
at the mothership that's a big deal so
what was the process like getting
permission or just pitching the idea of
filming a special there in the first
place oh that was actually the easiest
part honestly cuz like from you know
from the moment I met uh I met Rogan I
mean well at least from the moment he
saw me being funny you know he was like
oh I support you however I can whatever
you need don't need trip and you know
and I never asked him for nothing but
then I was like Hey I want to feel my
special here he was like yeah October
ended with the release of old dads on
Netflix which sparked more debate online
about if this was a quality comedy movie
or Rony flop of a film what made this
story even more interesting is the
Rotten Tomato score for Bur movie was
abysmal in the critic rating but very
strong in the fan score some notable
standup specials from October include
Pete Holmes I am not for everyone and
Ralph Barbosa cabanga November 2023
started off hot with the biggest news
story being Nate baratti hosting
Saturday Night Live which received
excellent ratings and had plenty of
Comedy fans pumped up for Nate if you're
home I'm as shocked as you are that I'm
here so in mid November we saw the rise
of young Kil Tony golden ticket winner
Heath Cordes who was so electric on
stage during his historical 60 seconds
that many people are now questioning if
the kill Tony bucket is somehow rigged
is that a compliment for you and do you
have anything to say to those people who
think that the fix was in on your bucket
pole it very much is a compliment I'm
very flattered that people think that if
it is rigged I don't know about it I've
never met Tony before that Monday I had
a very huge moment me a couple months
ago where I was on a show with him but I
don't think he even knew I was there I
was like third on the lineup he was last
so yeah we never even met but um it was
it was very cool that we met that way
and once you walked on stage you
immediately got to laugh just by saying
the words I feel like I feel
like did you know that if you ever got
pulled that it was going to be a really
big moment or did it click during your
set like wow I'm doing something very
special right now yeah I I knew would
take people off guard but I mean I've
seen a lot of people crush and so I
didn't know exactly how it would turn
out you know I wasn't betting on
anything but yeah it turned out way
better than I thought it would be uh
that voice crack completely organic it
helped everything definitely got the
ball rolling so far we've seen 47 of the
most relevant and interesting comedy
news stories from the year of 2023 and
although controversial our next video is
no different crystalia releasing his new
special on his own website behind a pay
wall after a full-on cancellation was
big news and objectively plays into an
interesting Paradox that we've seen
developing in comedy of people who are
cancelled in mainstream Society but
continue to tour and put out work our
video was obviously not comparing the
reasons people got cancelled or making a
deeper statement about christalia it's
really just an impartial part of this
year's comedy news after a three-year
Hiatus from public life and avoiding the
podcast industry for over a decade
comedian Daniel TSH finally launched his
own podcast in November of 2023 titled
Tosh show this new podcast features
unconventional guests such as his wife's
gynecologist which is perfect for tsh's
comedic style focusing more on his own
commentary than the fame of the guest in
all honesty this is the reason I agreed
to do this show iHeart was like will we
do the show and I'm like I don't know I
don't want to interview comedians I
don't want to interview celebrities but
like if you let and I said this I swear
to you I said if you let me interview
like my wife's gynecologist like then
I'll do the show and they're like well
yeah but that won't ever happen he
probably won't let you and I'm not that
interesting no you're extremely
interesting around the end of November
Matt R started making a ton of headlines
for outrage expressed by his female fan
base over a domestic abuse joke made
during his Netflix special you can tell
by who he is by the way he delivers
jokes by the way he does his crowd work
he goes in but in the most nonserious
way it's like watching Shane Gillis and
thinking he me like he means all of Y
dude he's this is where he he finds dark
funny mhm that's fine these Comics are
trying to make you laugh look at their
intent the intent is to make you laugh I
promise you Matt R is a very respectful
young man he's not out beating people
he's not pro domestic violence and that
joke is not making anybody go home and
hit their wife yeah you know what you
touchy you
touchy [__] just because it's not fun
for you doesn't mean other people aren't
having fun with it you don't get to be
the [__] fun police and you don't get
to police what other people think is
funny notable November standup specials
include Trevor Wallace pterodactyl
Whitney Cummings mouthy and Matt rif
natural selection we ended this crazy
year with back-to-back interviews the
First with tiger G the director of a
short film starring Bobby Lee titled
death and ramen so after creating this
film with Bobby is he as crazy as people
say and do you have any funny stories
from his time on set you know it was
really interesting because I had
expected there to be some separation
from Bobby the Persona on stage and on
screen and who he is in real life that
guy is the whole package you know is as
wonderful and insane in person as he is
uh as a Persona there's a little bit of
farting there's a but but surprisingly
he was incredibly like kind to to his
crew and and me like there's something
quite fatherly about him too there's a
lot of like interesting stories uh to
how we got to set though we met over
Korean barbecue uh before we decided to
shoot the movie you know he shows up
like 15 minutes late and and and like he
wait he's like 5 foot4 right he comes in
but the whole room like in Korean
barbecue restaurant kind of just stops
and and they stare at him and we sit
down and before we make it to our table
he like grabs me by the shoulder he
turns me around he goes I'm paying today
and then he takes home the takeout you
know so it's like that's like Bobby in
in a nutshell followed by perhaps our
most Monumental accomplishment yet the
Tom sagora interview I just want
watching your special Mostly stories my
freshman year of college was one of the
main things that really got me
interested in comedy and standup in
general so it's just a really cool thing
to get to talk to you all these years
later thanks man thanks I appreciate
that I like I said congratulations on um
on what you've built and uh I think you
know keep going because you're filling
something that that that needs to be
filled with like that space I think it's
very smart that you did this thank you
that means a lot appreciate it it is
pretty crazy to think we started this
year off talking about Tom sagora and we
ended the year talking to Tom sagora an
incredible feat made entirely possible
by everyone watching this video we truly
have the best subscribers in the world
that make up a community of people who
are educated and passionate about comedy
which is why we're having you vote the
joke World Awards is a fan driven annual
award show that will take place right
here on this YouTube channel categories
for the joke World Awards include
comedian of the Year podcast of the Year
podcast guest of the Year special of the
year not on YouTube YouTube special of
the year and newcomer of the Year voting
will begin on December 30th 2023 and
will be open for one week until our
Reveal video comes out going over all
the different votes and crowning the
winner for each category I know after
the JFL comedian of the Year video a lot
of people were saying there should be an
official fan vote so here it is start
thinking about who you want to vote for
for each of those categories and hit
subscribe so you don't miss the video
when voting goes live I think this could
be a really fun new tradition obviously
this will be the first year but thank
you for an incredible 2023 it was really
an awesome ride I love to bring in you
guys the comedy news and I can't wait to
see what videos we're going to make in
2024 joke
world that's did it joke
world and the world is
wld that's a great uh YouTube channel
joke World check it out